this is mexico's premier police force
the national guard president andres
manuel lopez obrador created it in 2019.
if it looks militarized it is four out
of five of its rank and file are from
the army and navy and it's commanded by
a general
but now lopez obrador wants to take
things a step further taking overall
control of the national guard and its
more than 100 000 members from civilian
authorities and placing it under the
defence ministry the army
the only reason for this is to
consolidate it and to maintain its
discipline and professionalism and most
of all for it not to get corrupted
the president's proposal has already
been passed by the lower chamber of
congress despite the opposition saying
it will lead to more militarization
no we will not allow a permanent state
of siege to be established in this
country as the president of the republic
intends
now it faces the senate if it clears
that hurdle it will likely be challenged
as unconstitutional ngos and civil
society are rallying against it
under president lopez obrador the army's
already had a bigger role in civilian
affairs than in recent memory taking
over the building of the capital's new
airport and a massive tourism railway
project in the south helping to deal
with the covert response too
there's a reason why that scares people
latin america has a long history of 20th
century military dictatorships
in the last 80 years mexico's avoided
that learning a lesson after a
succession of generals come presidents
following its revolution things won't
change now says the president
the purpose is not the militarization or
to go towards authoritarianism but to
take care under the vigilance of the
defense secretary the healthy growth of
what should be the main public security
institution of the country
the other question is if the measures
passed will putting the army in complete
control of the national guard actually
reduce mexico's violence we can look at
what's happened in years past to help
answer that the army itself has been on
the streets in mexico for more than a
decade helping the police and during
that time homicides have gone up rather
than down it's been accused and
regularly of human rights abuses and
also just lacking the intelligence and
investigative policing skills to really
tackle crime in this country
those who fear the army's growing role
or its impact on law and order in the
country will be watching what happens
closely john holman al jazeera mexico
city